as far as we can tell the five
conservative supreme court justices are
standing firm for life in the face of
leftist violence and intimidation
senate republicans are standing firm to
oppose court packing to oppose a law to
permit abortion nationwide this is the
hottest and most consequential political
issue of my lifetime and republican
politicians in charge of law enforcement
are completely dropping the ball last
night the leftist mob showed up to
justice sam alito's house to intimidate
his family and pressure him to change
his vote on overruling roe v wade
[Applause]
[Applause]
is a coward
you're a coward alito
[Applause]
this is illegal
they are in a residential neighborhood
and what they are doing protesting
outside of alito's home to intimidate
him and his family into changing his his
opinion is illegal according to 18 u.s
code section 1507 it is illegal to
protest in or near a building or
residence occupied or used by such judge
juror witness or court officer this is
not some authoritarian fantasy i'm
having or some obscure provision of the
law
this is a basic rule to protect the
integrity of our courts even the
libertarians are calling for its
enforcement okay there's an article in
reason.com
pointing out that it is illegal for this
mob to be doing this and law enforcement
should go in and enforce the law
where's glenn younkin
where where is the governor of virginia
where's more importantly where's federal
law enforcement why aren't the
psycholeftists who are threatening
judges kids in handcuffs right now
whatever happened to peace through
strength whatever happened to the rule
of law we're not talking about ordinary
protests here either we're talking about
what chief justice john roberts called a
singular and egregious leak
and violation of trust on the supreme
court followed by the doxing of judges
who are now visited by angry mobs as
leftists bomb and vandalize pro-life
centers around the country this is not
the time to go limp passions are high
because we are talking about a matter of
life and death i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the drummer's
workshop at norm's music who says in
jamaica abortions are illegal considered
a felony and anti-abortion songs are
common
one of the most popular dancehall songs
murder she wrote is about a woman with a
bad character and the murder is
referring to abortion
this is a great point and so many
americans don't know this liberals and a
lot of conservatives
america is the outlier when it comes to
abortion
you're hearing a lot of people now say
america's regressing we're one of the
only countries to go backwards on
abortion rights and make it more
restrictive america has some of the most
insanely open abortion laws in the world
our abortion laws are way more radical
than the abortion laws in france the
abortion laws in italy the abortion laws
in germany the abortion laws pretty much
anywhere else around the world other
than north korea china and canada okay
but other than those countries
all fairly evil countries these days but
i'm not sure which one takes the cake
other than those countries
america has some of the most open laws
maybe we should take a note from
all the rest of the countries around the
world which protect life at least today
much more than the united states does
all right we got to protect our families
okay you've got to protect your
household which is why you got to check
out american home shield right now go to
ahs.com
knowles do you want peace of mind you
want to stay on a budget sounds pretty
good right now doesn't it well if
there's one thing you can expect this
year it is the unexpected that is why
american home shield exists as a member
you know that your budget time and your
sanity are covered choose a plan from
american home shield and keep your
budget goals in check for 2022 they
offer a choice of three great plans to
help cover the cost to repair or replace
parts of major home appliances and
systems
no matter their age if american home
shield cannot repair the covered item
they will replace it american home
shield members get more more coverage
options fewer exclusions
we're talking about hvac systems and
plumbing to kitchen appliances their
plans help protect parts of up to 23
essential home systems and appliances
coverage available no matter the
circumstances so right now they're
offering an exclusive 50 off for our
listeners keep your home up and running
keep your budget on track with american
home shield right now get that
dollars off their most comprehensive
plans ever ahs.com slash knowles save 50
bucks ahs.com knowles for 50 bucks off
any plan service fees limitations and
exclusions apply c plan for details
american home shield be sure with the
shield
the good news
this is a according to another leak so
who know i guess the supreme court is
now the leakiest institution in the
country but the good news according to
this leak is that at least as recently
as two weeks ago the supreme court
majority was still holding strong to
overrule roe v wade now we don't know if
this has changed since
the leak of the opinion and the protests
and the threats against the judges and
against their families
but that that leaked draft of the court
opinion that was from february so a lot
could have changed since then and yet
according to some supreme court clerks
uh three conservatives close to the
court
uh the majority of five justices to
strike down roe remains intact that's
according to the washington post so
again take it with a grain of salt the
way that this breakdown is going to work
according to well one the leak of the
opinion but then according to the
washington post here is that it's going
to be 5-4 to overall roe vs wade that
the court is actually going to vote 6-3
to uphold the pro-life law in
mississippi that is at the heart of the
dobbs decision
but that chief justice john roberts is
going to squish he's going to try to to
split the baby as it were he's going to
try to uphold the abortion law in
mississippi the the pro-life law but
he's going to try to also uphold roe vs
wade in planned parenthood v casey at
least to a large degree
the five more conservative justices on
the court
said sorry chief justice that's not
going to work for us and so they're
going to break away according to this
reporting they're going to break away
from the chief justice and they're going
to form a court majority to overrule roe
versus white and planned parenthood be
casey they're going to form a court
majority to get rid of the completely
fictional right to abortion in the
constitution that that a bunch of
political activists discovered in 1973
they are going to restore some
integrity to our judicial system at
least according to to the reporting
right now
but if you
are married if you've got young kids and
you've got an angry violent mob
you've got an angry mob outside of your
home and you've got violent pro-abortion
activists firebombing pro-life centers
around the country
that could influence your voting i hope
it does not i think that if the the
conservatives on the court change their
votes now it will so destroy the
integrity of that institution it will
just be an open license to the violent
mob to whenever whenever they get the
inkling that the court's not going to
rule their way to just go and throw a
molotov cocktail and then everything
will be hunky-dory as far as they're
concerned so it would be disastrous i
think if anything what i'm hoping is
that the the mobs have hardened the
conservatives opinions on this
but they're they're not giving up the
left truly believes that threats and
intimidation and violence
are going to win the day for them
over the weekend on sunday a number of
pro-abortion lunatics were disrupting
masses
we're going to catholic churches around
the country
one group of these lunatics put on some
handmaid's tale outfits and showed up in
a catholic mass at the cathedral in los
angeles
[Music]
[Music]
and without
[Music]
the symbolism here is actually perfect
because these
wackos have showed up during communion
so this is
the holiest moment of the mass when the
the priest is consecrating the host and
he's saying
repeating the words of christ this is my
body which will be given up for you and
catholics believe that at
that moment the bread the bread and the
wine is transformed uh through
transubstantiation into the literal body
and blood of christ so that so that god
is in a very tangible way with you in
the room this is my body which will be
given up for you and and the
pro-abortion activists bust in there at
this extraordinarily sacred moment of
the mass
and they
ironically
invert
the message they say no this is my body
and you're gonna
your body little baby it's actually my
body and your body is going to be given
up for me this is my body peter craft
the philosopher made this point he said
the way that you know that abortion is
the sacrament of the antichrist
is that
even the the sloganeering for it
is is the same it's the same wording of
the eucharist itself but with a
blasphemously inverted meaning this is
my body that's the chant that you're
hearing all over the place but instead
of a man giving up his life for his
friends one man dying so that all may
live
you have you have the opposite you have
people sacrificing their own children
just for their own desires just for
their what they what they think will be
for their own benefit actually actually
will not be for their own benefit but
they don't they don't understand that so
they're willing to do the pro-abortion
activists are willing to do just about
anything nothing
is too sacred for them to disrupt no
norm no standard is is to be held so
highly in esteem that they're not going
to violate it of course that's what i
said when when the supreme court opinion
leaked i said of course they leaked the
opinion these are people who kill babies
of course they're going to leave they
don't care about a supreme court norm or
standard if you're willing to kill your
child you're willing to do just about
anything so what do we do about this
the reaction so far generally speaking
from law enforcement has been hands off
just like outside of sam alito's house
oh well
yeah it's against the law to
show up and intimidate judges and try to
change their opinion but hey let's all
just let's just be cool right we're not
going to arrest anybody well that's what
they're doing here at this mass but what
what those protesters did is illegal it
is illegal to do that
it's ironic because there's actually
it's a provision of a pro-abortion law
that actually protects churches from
these lunatics it's the freedom of
access to clinic entrances act of 1994
prohibits the use or threat of force or
physical obstruction that injures
intimidates or interferes with a person
seeking to obtain or provide an abortion
that same law also to appease the
pro-lifers when this is being passed uh
also prohibits people from doing all
those things to exercise the first
amendment right of religious freedom at
a place of religious worship so what
those wackos are doing is illegal and do
you know what we should do there's two
opinions on this
the squishes and the nice guys they say
hey let's just let it go let's just let
them well do their thing that's silly
and then we'll just kind of ask them
politely to leave no arrest them arrest
them this has gone on way too long we
have let this go way too far if you want
if you want to stop a
perverse and disordered behavior you
need to punish that behavior okay and
and this is really bad for our civil
society it's really bad for our system
of law you need to arrest these people
and throw them in jail and teach them a
lesson naughty naughty no showing up and
screaming and disrupting mass naughty
naughty no terrorizing
brett kavanaugh's children or sam
alito's family or any naughty naughty
you're not going to do that anymore and
if you do we're going to arrest you and
if you do it again we're going to throw
you in jail for longer
you've got to get tough folks it's tough
love okay
but there's no compassion or loving
nothing loving about letting these
people terrorize the ordinary
law-abiding american citizens we've got
to stand firm this is the issue it's why
you got to check out 40 days for life
right now go to 40daysforlife.com
okay
we are on the cusp of overruling roe vs
wade you may think that means the fight
is coming to an end no
that means abortion legislation very
likely will return to the the states or
even the federal government there's no
group in america better positioned than
40 days for life to help fight this
battle 40 days for life has 1 million
volunteers throughout the country
holding peaceful vigils outside of
abortion facilities you may be surprised
to hear that their largest presence is
actually in the country's blue states
california is their biggest state the
vigils have closed many abortion
facilities in america nearly half of
those facilities were in liberal states
where abortion will remain legal after
row
from san francisco to chicago to seattle
not not extremely pro-life areas
volunteers have guided abortion workers
to have a change of heart and quit their
jobs so as this issue gets out of dc
finally 40 days for life is effectively
changing hearts and minds in the
grassroots of the pro-abortion movement
check out their locations podcast and
their new book what to say when the
complete guide to discussing abortion at
40daysforlife.com
this issue of the the protests around
the dobbs decision the overruling of roe
versus wade it's not just about
speech that i don't like it's not just
about the free marketplace of ideas well
you can protest for life and you can
protest for abortion we are seeing
actual violence taking place right now
and it's not being reported very often
in the
establishment media because they want to
completely cover this up because it's
inconvenient for their narrative but
there are acts of violence taking place
right now
pro-life pregnancy centers are under
attack daily wires got some great
reporting on this okay we've got
kaiser oregon the oregon right to life
announced on monday evening that its
offices in kaiser had been attacked late
sunday they said in a statement an
individual used incendiary devices one
of which exploded and caught the
building on fire that's that's that's
the latest in the mostly peaceful
protests that we've been seeing from the
left in recent years so uh that that was
over in oregon madison wisconsin a
pro-life non-profit was set on fire in a
quote suspicious fire molotov cocktail
thrown into the pro-life organization's
building one wall was burnt we reported
on this message yesterday if abortions
aren't safe then you aren't either
you can see the the pictures here are
really disturbing anarchist symbols all
over the place that's in madison's
wisconsin frederick maryland
on wednesday may 4th the staff arrived
at a pro-life center in frederick
maryland to this disturbing scene of
lies and propaganda spray painted on the
building this is carenet and that's
according to the care net executive
director linda king
uh she says unfortunately this is not
the first time our center has been
vandalized we were previously vandalized
twice in 2014 in the same manner you've
got all sorts of hideous graffiti all
over the walls this is not legal stuff
this is not any kind of protected
protest all right they've been they've
been going on all
over the country
if we do not enforce the law
if we do not arrest these criminals and
help to solve our massive
under-incarceration problem in this
country and and give people a little bit
of
of
justice
and then you're going to see more of it
and that's what they want this is by the
way this is why the law is not being
enforced is because the republicans are
too cowardly and because the democrats
want to see more of this they want more
uh pro-life centers to be attacked they
want the justices families to be
threatened and intimidated the white
house for goodness sakes the white house
was asked hey are you really you think
that angry mobs should show up to judges
private homes and what did jen saki say
she said we don't have an official
government position on where people
protest
f around and find out that's that's that
was the translation of what she was
saying
yeah sorry
yes that's
it's a nice house she got it's a nice
family you got there brett kavanaugh
sure would be a shame if something
happened to it
maybe yeah maybe you should reconsider
your vote
really really disgusting stuff
we are winning on this issue and we are
on the cusp of a major pro-life victory
we've got to keep up the strength you
can't just let these people do this and
run roughshod over our country you can't
just let these criminals and terrorists
try to
try to pull this victory away from
americans who support it
now believe it or not i know mitch
mcconnell gets a lot of a lot of
criticism but mr cocaine himself has
come out here he has been
one of if not the most important leader
on this issue
cocaine mitch was just asked if assuming
roe v wade is overruled and assuming
that this issue goes back to the
legislatures back to the states maybe
but even possibly the federal
legislature could there be a law
outlawing abortion nationwide
and
cocaine mitch was asked this by usa
today and he said
if the luke to punish
him i'm kind of doing a rand paul that's
not that's not quite that's i gotta work
on my cocaine mitch if the leaked
opinion became the final opinion
legislative bodies not only at the state
level but at the federal level
certainly could legislate in that area
and if this were the final decision that
was the point and that that it should be
resolved one way or another in the
legislative process
so yeah
it's possible
mitch mcconnell does not get a ton of
credit for his rock solid conservative
principles i don't know if mitch
mcconnell has rock solid conservative
principles i suspect he does not
however
if roe v wade is overruled
and especially if there's a national
abortion ban could you imagine
cocaine mitch deserves the lion's share
of the credit
this is the guy
who
who held up the replacement of antonin
scalia
this is the guy
who rammed through those conservative
judges this is the guy he said his
lasting legacy is the judges
and the judges
may
very soon overrule roe versus wade this
is the guy who did it
just like people say well donald trump's
an imperfect vessel for some very good
ideas and very good things in the
country you'd have to say the same thing
about mitch mcconnell i don't know what
mitch mcconnell personally thinks about
abortion but if this goes through if the
if the
roe v wade is overruled he deserves a
whole lot of credit and then as he's
saying now if there if there were a
national abortion law
the guy would be one of the great heroes
of pre-born babies in the history of the
world
this guy would be one of the truly one
of the greatest statesmen
in history
and it could happen another reason why
this is important too for republicans to
get behind this kind of talk is
it it will allow
in a very cynical way it will allow
republicans to continue to raise money
off of all of us pro-lifers
one of the
issues with the pro-life movement for
the past 50 years with regard to the
republican party is that the republicans
relied on pro-lifers to give them a lot
of money to get rid of abortion but the
problem there of course is if roe v wade
is overruled the republicans feared that
they would lose the money from the
pro-lifers because the problem would
have gone away and so there was a kind
of a perverse incentive there for the
republicans not to really fight that
hard against abortion because they were
making so much money from the pro-lifers
but as we have said on this show many
times roe v wade is not the end of the
story you overrule roe v wade that's not
the end of the fight that's really just
the beginning of the fight because the
fight here is not just for some
procedural aspect of our judiciary or
some
uh interesting reading of the text of
the constitution and some long lecture
about federalism the point is to protect
babies and so i don't want there to be
abortion in california i don't want
there to be abortion in new york i do
not respect the right so-called of new
yorkers or californians to have abortion
i think it's wrong all the time
everywhere it's just wrong to kill
babies and so the pro-life fight is
going to have to continue there whether
that's by fighting for laws in the
states or whether that's fighting for a
federal law so we'll this will allow
republicans to continue to raise money
off of all of us pro-lifers and it's
going to give us another place to look
after roe v wade becomes
history
why is cocaine mitch going after this as
well
one i think it's the right thing to do
i'll give him credit for it two i think
it's
obviously the next step in this movement
but three it's a political winner it's a
big political winner it's not just some
niche issue for extremely far-right
conservatives pro-life is a winning
message for americans period full stop
bill maher just proved my point i've
been on this hobby horse for a very long
time and i've been i've been shouting it
from the rooftops bill maher just proved
my point when when on his show he said
he didn't want to talk about abortion
but you know this is the big topic this
week and so he was going to talk about
it and he said you know by golly
i had i had no idea a lot of the things
i thought i knew about abortion turns
out they were just totally false
you know it's interesting because until
this memo was leaked and we found out
that now unless something we very
unforeseen happens the supreme court is
going to
undo roe vs wade after 49 years we
haven't really been focusing on it or
maybe i'm projecting i guess i haven't
been enough because
i learned things this week because this
put it on the front page that are pretty
basic things that i did not know
about abortion
like in europe
the modern countries of europe way more
restrictive than we are or what they're
even proposing if you are pro-choice
you would like it a lot less in germany
and italy and france and spain and
switzerland did you know that i didn't
know that i didn't know that that's
right okay um i learned most people who
are pro-life are women
did not know that
did you know that yes you probably did
if you're listening to this show you
probably pay
a little more attention to politics than
most people do and you probably know a
little bit more of the arguments and you
probably know a little bit more of the
facts
i suspect most americans are like bill
maher though
i suspect most americans
don't pay extraordinarily close
attention and so they don't realize yeah
most pro-lifers are women they don't
realize what the abortion laws are in
france and germany and italy and
pretty much everywhere else around the
world
more restrictive than they are in the
and
united
not their fault even that they don't
know they have been inundated with
propaganda lies from
hollywood from the press
from
the educational institutions
and so they it's it's not even that
they're ignorant as ronald reagan said
it's just that they know so many things
that are not so
now that we're beginning to crack that
monopoly on information
now that we're beginning to just get the
reality of abortion out there
it's a huge
political winner people see the reality
of what abortion is
and they just don't like it
speaking of opening up lines of
communication i am super duper excited
to announce that starting this friday
our listeners can send in
voice mailbags that's right thanks to
our friends at pure talk you can send a
voice memo to my mailbag and we will
play it on the show and then i will get
to hear your dulcet and mellifluous
tones and i will get to answer your
question and it will be more human and
it will it will be a much more intimate
connection so make sure to send those in
also all the episodes right now are
streaming of fouchy unmasked they are
exclusively at the daily wire it is
really important to watch this the libs
are not done with kovid they keep trying
to bring it back they keep trying
they're fighting the white house is
fighting tooth and nail to put their
mask mandate back into place dr fauci
he's hiding at witness protection for
now but then it'll pop up every so often
he just received an honorary degree at a
university you would have thought this
man were were an angel walking on earth
you the the way that this man was being
idolized and adored they're going to try
to bring him back take a listen
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr
fauci began to set national policy that
affected the way that 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you where a mask keeps
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
dr anthony
don't you think it's time that you step
down and let someone else who has a more
effective message
actually no
[Music]
the full series is available now at the
daily wire if you're not a member yet go
to dailywire.com subscribe to join today
and for a limited time new members can
use code knowles kwls for 20 off your
membership the show is excellent and
since we are only adding more content
every day you do not want to miss it
we'll be right back with a lot more
i've been a little disappointed
looking at the republican senate race in
pennsylvania this is going to be a big
year according to all the indicators for
republicans this should be a massive
republican wave the conservatives are
winning on every single issue joe biden
is underwater on every single issue the
guy can barely say his own name this is
it this is our moment conservatives and
at the moment it looks as though
conservatives are going to nominate
a
liberal television talk show host to be
their
candidate this would be dr oz uh dr oz
there are lots of tapes of him
whining about pro-life laws around the
country very very recently there's not
much evidence that dr oz has any
conservative inclinations in his entire
body this is nothing against him i don't
know dr oz nothing against him
personally but the guy just doesn't seem
like a conservative he can prove me
wrong but i just don't see it and
unfortunately dr oz has received
donald trump's endorsement
so he he was the candidate a lot of
trump supporters myself included
were puzzled we were scratching our
heads over this endorsement of doctor uh
why dr oz
but then the other candidate in the race
is david mccormick
again
don't know much about david mccormick he
does he also doesn't seem like he's got
the strongest toughest conservative
bonafides either david mccormick is a
self-funder dr oz has a lot of money too
so these are the two top candidates
there were other people running but they
just didn't have any money and so it
looked like it was going to be one of
these two guys and it was a little
dispiriting for the conservative base
and then
out of nowhere well not out of nowhere
actually but suddenly up comes
kathy barnett
kathy barnett
is a
conservative political commentator she's
a veteran she's a former adjunct
professor of corporate finance she's a
wife she's a mother she homeschooled her
kids she's
she she's a real conservative she checks
out
she when you look down the list she
checks all the boxes of of a real
conservative but she didn't have any
money there was just no way she was
going to win this race and then out of
nowhere there's a poll
of 1000 more than 1 000 likely
republican primary voters by the
trafalgar group
and according to this poll
out of nowhere kathy barnett is now in a
statistical tie
with dr oz and david mccormick
dr oz currently leads the race but he's
only got 24 and a half percent kathy
barnett is 23.2
so about about a point away
and then uh this hedge fund manager and
uh treasury official david mccormick
comes in at 21.6 so mccormick despite
all of his money he's actually behind
kathy barnett at the moment by the way
the margin of error is three percent so
the candidates are in a statistical tie
and the craziest part of all is do you
know why kathy barnett is surging i
think because kathy barnett
is the
pro-life candidate not only is kathy
barnett pro-life in her policies
kathy barnett
is the product of rape kathy barnett
according to the liberals should have
been killed in the womb through abortion
because the of the tragic way that she
was conceived and kathy barnett is out
there and she says hey hey guys look i
know i know this is the extreme end of
arguing on the abortion debate but if
you if you want to go there if you if
you actually if you want to justify
abortion then you're saying that i
should have been killed as a baby
i am the byproduct of a rape my mother
was 11 years old when i was conceived my
father was 21. i was not just a lump of
cells as you can see i'm still not just
a lump of cells my life has value
my life has value that's a very powerful
message
and
i don't think this woman is surging in
the polls despite that message what the
establishment conservative consensus
says is
look just run on tax cuts just run on
deregulation run on let people do
whatever they want just keep cutting my
taxes
and look if you need to talk about
pro-life or whatever it's fine like
maybe you can still win in spite of that
but don't emphasize it keep going
certainly oh my gosh don't talk about
the extreme and edges of abortion just
talk about late-term abortion or
whatever well what about how do you
explain kathy barnett
how do you explain this woman
surging past so we're surging up to
candidates who have way more money way
more backing the endorsement of donald
trump the leader of the republican party
and this woman is jumping not in spite
of her pro-life views but because of
them
because she is the embodiment because
you look at her and you say oh yeah you
shouldn't have been killed look that
woman in the eye and say you should have
been killed as a baby
do it does anyone only the most hardened
psychopath would be able to look that
woman in the face and say the world
would be better had you been killed as a
baby people should have the right to
kill you you know i i generally don't uh
do primary endorsements um i'm i'm not
going to do a primary primary
endorsement here but i am greatly
encouraged by the fact that this woman
is surging that the conservatives
are
are looking and saying no we want
something a little deeper here
okay this is a moment where where we
it's not just about getting another r in
the senate
we like to get more r's in the senate
but we want to do some we want we want
people with moral clarity and vision
once they get to the senate
speaking of polls the polls are really
good for the r's right now
according to a civics poll of of 200 000
respondents almost across 50 states
only 36 percent
of registered voters approve of the job
joe biden is doing
54 disapprove
that net approved disapprove is an
absolute disaster for biden even crazier
biden only has net approval in four
states
56 i sound like barack obama all 57
states 46 states in this country
disapprove of joe biden
those are shocking numbers you haven't
seen that kind of political agreement
that kind of political unity in america
since the 80s you haven't seen that
since reagan 84 when ronald reagan took
49 states took took vast majority of
states in in 82.
nixon did too actually
the republicans have
historically actually done a pretty good
job at unifying the country
not in recent years but now i guess
we're back at it joe biden he joe biden
promised that he was going to unify
america and he did accidentally he did
unify america other than vermont
massachusetts maryland and hawaii every
other state disapproves of of joe biden
right now
do not let the libs intimidate us when
they show up to sam alito's house and
brett kavanaugh's house when they
firebomb pro-life centers when they show
up to your church and disrupt everything
they're doing it because they are
desperate we've got to deal with it
we've got to punish them we've got to
enforce the law
but do not
do not be discouraged
really you should be encouraged those
are the tactics a very weak very
desperate people right now
the law is on our side
the moral order is on our side and the
people are on our side you know our
democracy that the libs always love
talking about except when they lose our
democracy right now is firmly on the
side of conservatives and not just on
the weak squishy issues on the really
important essential issues to all the
way down to the issue of life why are
people so fed up with democrats it's the
economy of course the economy is in the
doldrums it's the the inflation the
record high inflation the record high
gas prices the fact that there's a baby
food shortage for goodness sakes the
baby formula shortage the fact that
there are there are issues in the food
supply just just generally throughout
the economy the fact that now we've got
the first major war in europe since
world war ii that's not good we've yes
there are all of these problems the fact
that immigration has never been worse
the fact that we've got
two million illegal aliens came into the
country last year and it's going to be
more than that this year on top of one
million legal immigrants but do you know
what else it is
it's all the weird creepy sex stuff it
bothers people
target right now is selling weird
transgender stuff for pride month
including to kids
target is teaming up with
tomboy x the tomboy x collection
includes this is at target a major
retailer
chest binders chest binders is when
women put on
very restrictive bras i guess to make it
look like they don't have breasts
packing underwear
i don't know exactly what that is but i
think i have a feeling and yuck bras boy
shorts in sizes small through 4x as
every size that there is they've got
swimsuit styles
bustle reported binders and gender
affirming gender affirming swimsuits
which means gender denying swimsuits are
notoriously difficult to find
particularly in extended sizes this
accessible drop will make shopping for
everyday garments easier yes this is the
top issue in our country right now right
so we we need to make sure that morbidly
obese sexual deviants can can put on
clothing that makes them play dress up
and pretend to be the opposite sex
that's that's what americans care about
that's a real dinner table issue
wouldn't you say no it's not it's not
and it's weird and not only is it weird
and kind of unusual and so therefore
people are resistant to it but it's
actually wrong they're pumping this kind
of propaganda into our kids as well kids
items in the target pride collection
include toddler teas that proclaim trans
rights or human rights and sure it's
emblazoned with pronouns with a rainbow
merchandise toddler books that include
bye bye binary and the pronoun book this
is just disgusting this is just awful
and we should pass laws against it to
stop target from doing it
okay the the slogans of of the last 10
years of a kind of feckless squishy
conservatism would have said well you
know target's a private company and uh
if you don't want uh mega international
corporations transgendering your
children well then build your own target
you have absolutely no right to tell
target that they can't transgender your
kids yes we do we do have that right
target doesn't have some kind of
constitutional right to trans the kids
we the people do have the rights as a
political community to stop pervert
corporations from transgendering our
kids we do have that right we can say no
no weird transgender stuff for kids is
is illegal boom done
pass me that law where can i where can i
find that law
you know we did we did the dr fauci
public health protection pledge i just
floated this idea on my show that i said
i won't vote for a federal candidate in
2022 who doesn't promise to get rid of
dr fauci to zero out his his salary and
then it's spread like wildfire and a ton
of candidates and a ton of sitting
members of the congress signed on to it
and then all of a sudden dr fatchi went
away
kind of interesting timing not saying it
was directly responsible but i'm not
saying it wasn't either well okay let's
bring up the next bill the uh stop
pervert corporations from transgendering
our kids bill
it's not a violation of the first
amendment it's not a violation of the
emanations or the penumbras or anything
else we have the right to standards in
this country and we have a right to stop
these sick predators from
perving on our kids and selling all
sorts of deviant stuff in our major
retailer stores it's just
this is not an
extreme view of mine okay this is a view
that would have been shared by 100 of
the population five years ago
three years ago
and it's a view that the majority of
americans continue to support today
okay this is how you explain the parents
movement in virginia that's how glenn
younkin got elected is because parents
didn't want weirdos transiting their
kids and filling their heads with racial
ideologies this is how you explain the
parents movement in florida okay this is
how you explain the the vast
the extreme popularity of this kind of
an issue
what is it
explain to me why why it's so wrong to
trans the kids explain to me why it's so
wrong to have this kind of public
religious worship of weird sexual
ideologies i could explain to you why
that is i think a lot of you out there
could articulate in words why this stuff
is so wrong but you actually don't need
to
and i think for the majority of parents
and the majority of americans who oppose
this stuff
maybe they can't articulate exactly why
it's it's so wrong to sell
chest binders and
and what is it on boxer packing
packing underwear and and bye bye binary
books to toddlers they might not be able
to articulate exactly why it's wrong in
precise philosophical terms but they
just know it's wrong it's called the
wisdom of repugnance and they're right
the late conservative philosopher roger
scrutiny said the job of the
conservative intellectual is to
articulate the sorts of things that
ordinary people know intuitively
okay and
ordinary regular old run-of-the-mill
people who are
going about their lives and their
families and their business and don't
have time to focus on all the creepy
predations of political activists all
day long they just know it's wrong
we should run on it's just like abortion
well it's different than abortion
they're separate issues in the substance
but the political effect is the same
the squishes and the establishmentarians
believe that
we shouldn't touch the trend don't touch
lgbtq
transiting the toddlers don't touch it
it's a culture war issue just run on the
economy no stupid no one cares about we
care about the economy we care about tax
rates we even sort of care about
marginal tax rates but nowhere near as
much as we care about these creeps
transiting our kids run on that don't
run away from pro-life run on pro-life
it's a winning message don't run away
from
this insane sexual revolution stuff run
on it this is a winning message people
care about their culture they care about
their standards and we have a right
to
to a public culture that is sane
and that that does not
that does not encourage this kind of
bizarre behavior that is extremely
destructive to everyone that it touches
it is time for republicans to pounce
you know this is what happens every time
the libs do something wrong
and then conservatives criticize them
for it what is the headline in the
newspaper the headline is republicans
pounce
liberals hold ritual human sacrifice and
that's not the headline the headline is
republicans pounce on
liberal religious display
republican they're always pouncing those
republicans they just pounce everywhere
i don't know something about our knees i
don't know we're so good at well guess
what now is the time to pounds in the
political arena on issues that are big
winners for all of us
the ohio house of representatives a
house committee in ohio
passed legislation
that would prohibit social media
companies from censoring users
this bill is hb441
this would block companies like twitter
facebook instagram and youtube from
censoring content based on ideas or
personal viewpoints
this bill would not apply to speech that
is illegal under federal law so there is
some speech that is just illegal
according to federal law direct threats
uh
obscenity though that's probably
actually not going to be enforced very
much
fraud so certain speeches is illegal
already
but other than that what this
ohio house committee says is other than
that social media can't censor people
this is good this is a good first step
it's and it's a sign that republicans
are beginning to think much more
seriously about the issue of free speech
because by the way
the issue isn't even that all censorship
is bad
wrote i wrote a whole book about this
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available in paperback next month
the issue is not that all censorship is
bad
the issue is
that this kind of censorship is really
really bad and it's especially bad the
way that they're doing it every society
has standards and taboos and says
certain things are off limits that's
always been true throughout the entire
history of the united states and every
other state too
but if we are going to censor certain
things if we're going to say that
certain things are off limits
it's actually much better to do it
through the government than through
private corporate quote-unquote private
corporations i know that sounds
unconventional i know that sounds
counter-intuitive given what we have all
thought of on the right for the past 10
or 15 years or so
but it's it's much better to do that if
there is inevitably going to be some
kind of censorship of some at least some
narrow topics
then you've got to do it through the
government because at least there's some
accountability there's the political
community we can at least go vote on
that
i can't go vote at facebook
i can't go vote at twitter maybe elon
musk will let me when he takes over but
i can't go vote at google okay
if there were a thriving free
marketplace of ideas where there were
200 social media companies and they were
all competing with one another then you
would not have as much of a need for
government action because then there
would be some competition and i could go
over and i could go on the conservative
social media platform and that'll just
be fine but that's not how it actually
works these are monopolies they might
even be natural monopolies but they
certainly are monopolies they've they
have
gathered critical mass through
exploiting legal loopholes and through
fraud in some cases
you're not going to build your own
google
you're not going to build your own
twitter the best you can do is buy your
own twitter by the way and even that's
going to be very difficult to do
so
all the situation you've got right now
is that the libs
are using the handful of big tech
companies as a proxy for them to censor
us
it's just it's just the libs
who
would prefer to censor us through the
government but they realize it's
actually easier to just use the big tech
companies to do it and so what we need
to do is assert our political rights the
few that we still have left and go in
there and say no you're we're not going
to do we're actually going to fight the
libs in government through the proxy of
the social media companies and say no
you're not going to censor conservatives
we've got we've got to pounce we've got
to use this power now while we've got it
ron desantis gets it
ron desantis
just issued a mandate i know
conservatives used to hate mandates they
were reflexively would would recoil from
them
but sometimes it's good to use mandates
and ron desantis just issued a mandate
that
public high schools in florida have to
observe victims of communism day
i love this so
much
uh ron desantis did this after the miami
young republicans
suggested this bill i actually was
talking to the president of the miami
young republicans armando ibarra when i
was down there doing an event some
months ago and he mentioned this this
idea and it's just really impressive
that this miami young republicans group
has gone and actually gotten this this
pushed through the legislature and up to
the governor's desk this is a great law
in school
you are always going to have
some kind of
moral and ethical and yes even religious
instruction that's always going to
happen
america always knew this and so the
instruction was christian with some
carvats if people were not christian
then in the 1950s 60s middle of the 20th
century
a bunch of political radicals went in
and said no no christianity whatsoever
we got to kick it out of the schools no
bible no prayer no nothing but there
wasn't no nothing all they did was
replace public christianity with public
liberalism we still have feast days and
liturgical calendars and all that kind
of stuff in the public schools that are
celebrated it's just all for liberalism
not for christianity
there are pride month festivities all in
virtually every public school in america
now
there are special holidays there's earth
day earth day is very frequently
celebrated in public schools now there
are secular saints that are celebrating
all sorts of sexual moral maxims
well okay if we're if we're if we're
always going to have something that's
sacred something that's celebrated
something that's commemorated we should
commemorate the victims of communism
you know you know a lot of public
schools are commemorating the victims of
january 6th of which there were none
there were not no one no one was
murdered on january 6th despite
headlines to the contrary
but there are all sorts of days so a day
of quiet a day of not showing up to
class a moment of silence after donald
trump won the election okay let's have a
moment of silence for victims of leftism
for victims of communism for victims of
marxism
that's a great idea that is a great use
of public power
we're just talking about the target
story over pride month they've got
they're selling all of these things
pride month is a liturgical event it's a
religious event by the way i thought
pride month was june what day it's may
10th why are we already in pride month
that means that now the lgbt activists
get june and may
and october by the way they get october
october is lgbt history month
that's a quarter of the year that
they've got so far three out of 12
months
that is
religious okay and that's extreme and
that's radical and that's very unpopular
why is ron desantis doing this in
florida because there's a ton of cubans
in florida one he's doing it because
it's the right thing to do i hope but
two there's a ton of cubans who hate
communism it's good politics too
sometimes the right thing
and the politically popular thing
sometimes those coincide conservatives
are in one of those moments right now on
life on culture on the rule of law and
we should run with it as far as we can
i'm michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show